you're gonna be disgusted when you hear  how evil this company is this corrupt  Oil Company went into Nigeria and ruined  the land they filled the water supply  with cancer-causing pollution they  killed off all the fish and the farmland  and when people started protesting to  stop exploiting their country all this  company had to do was go to the Nigerian  government and allegedly say if you want  us to keep lining your pockets you  better get your military to take care of  these protesters in an instant these  protesters Fates were sealed this  private multinational corporation now  had an entire standing army and the  result was brutal guns went off grenades  were thrown as the military launched a  full-on assault against all those  protesters 80 people were killed and  almost 600 houses were burned down and  the name of this evil company is shell  which is why